bienvenue dans l'entretien de france 24
mon invité aujourd'hui vient de finir
une saison phénoménale fils rentre tout
juste de norvège où il a été sacré
meilleur biathlète du monde de la saison
bonjour quentin fillon va y est merci
beaucoup de répondre aux questions de
france 24 après vos cinq médailles à
pékin on les voit là elles sont entre
nous vous venez donc dont deux médailles
en or vous venez de remporter le gros
globe de cristal sacré globe à côté de
vous au championnat du monde de norvège
deux petits globes au sprint et en
poursuite
est ce que vous avez eu le temps de
réaliser la saison que vous venez de
faire pas tout à fait en fait beaucoup
de gens ne me rende me disent tu te
rends compte de ce qui vient de se
passer mais les choses sont pas arriver
du jour au lendemain on fait ça j'y ai
tellement penser tellement travaillé
pour que ben acs pas quelque chose qui
donc je suis surpris je suis surpris de
ramené cinq médailles d'or cinq
médailles à des jeux olympiques mais pas
surpris de ce qui s'est vraiment
réaliser et finalement me voilà ça
arrive pas du jour au lendemain est
tellement et re voila de tout ça il
devrait de concrétiser une saison
quasiment parfaite on est en fin de
saison là vous êtes épuisé vous êtes
encore dans l'adrénaline non en fait
tout au long de la saison on a beaucoup
l'enchaînement de beaucoup de courses et
jeux olympiques arrivent vraiment au
milieu et c'est pas si c'est vraiment
une étape dans dans la saison qui est
très importante mais qui qui se confond
presque avec les coupes du monde parce
que on se retrouve vraiment sur un
enchaînement très dense des courses
quasiment tous les deux jours pendant
quatre mois avec les transports et les
le qu'ovide aussi qui rajoute aussi de
la complexité à tous a donc finalement
ça a été assez éprouvant et durant toute
la saison j'ai essayé de ne pas trop
profiter justement de des médailles ou
des émotions pour des deux focalise déjà
sur la suite et
aller toucher ben justement mes deux
objectifs de saison qui était un
médaille d'or individuelle et gros globe
de cristal je me dis ben j'aurais toute
la vie pour profiter de tout ça après ça
fait une dizaine d'années que vous
faites du biathlon en compétition vous
avez gagné en niveau avec une assez
belle régularité au fil des années
la 2022 clairement enfin 2021-2022
c'était pour vous est ce que vous diriez
qu'il ya une forme de déclic ça fait les
trois les trois saisons avant j'ai fait
3e mondial avec 10 médailles sur les
championnats du monde en individuel pas
de médailles d'or et une troisième à 6
3e place pour rang mondial qui
qui me qui me satisfaisait mais pas
totalement parce que finalement je me
dis est ce qu'un jour je vais être
capable de vraiment gagner le graal et
donc ça a été la recherche un peu de
toute la préparation d'essayer de faire
évoluer l'approché mentale de mes
courses de ma préparation de de tous
d'avoir plus de confiance et
je suppose qu'à qui a plutôt bien marché
parce que finalement j'ai beaucoup
d'investissements sans garantie de
réussite il est au final voilà ça ça
payait et ça ça a vraiment un pays comme
le souhaitait le graal est là à côté de
vous et pourtant on a l'impression que
et vous en faut toujours plus on vous
sait déçu de ne pas avoir gagné un
troisième petit globe celui de la mass
start alors que vous avez remporté celui
ci comme vous avez été déçu lors de la
dernière course à pékin lors vous aviez
déjà cinq médailles on les voit là
autour de votre cou est ce qu'il faut
être à ce point insatiable pour être bon
et surtout pour le rester j'essaie de
cultiver la la volonté de la victoire et
uniquement la victoire donc au jeu quand
je termine 4ème de la mass-start m'a
acheté déçu de pas aller chercher grand
chelem sur sur ça et quand sur la fin de
la fin des des coupes du monde termine
2e du petit globe de la mass-start bas à
2 points sur je suis pas 500 points à
peu près gta j'étais frustré sur le coup
j'ai eu du mal à profiter de du fait que
la saison était finie bon après ça va
vite été effacés quand une fois qu'on
m'a donné ce bel objet parce que je me
rends compte voilà que la saison elle
est le plus qui a réussi mes voyages et
cette volonté d'en vouloir plus et puis
pas me contenter de simplement ce que
que je pourrais avoir à portée de main
ou ce qu'on va me donner donc les choses
c'est ce qui me permet de continuer volé
je pense que ça me permettra aussi
d'être
encore j'espère très bon pour la suite
ouais c'est comme ça qu'on garde
l'appétit même quand on vient de passer
une saison comme ça pour la suite ouais
en fait mon bonheur c'est de faire je
suis aujourd'hui de réussir en biathlon
j'aime aussi mon sport pas toujours
marrant mais j'aime j'aime vraiment ce
que je fais elle est montrée nice ou la
puce et c'est pas toujours évident mais
ça fait partie de ceux préparation et
puis j'en suis fier parce que finalement
c'est une vraie réalisation au delà de
10 objets qui sont ici c'est la
réalisation humaine le partager et donc
c'est mon bonheur et c'est ce qui c'est
ce que je vais continuer à faire en fin
de saison et on comprend pourquoi vous
qui aimez la compétition de très haut
niveau il manquait des concurrents de
premier plan comme et younes b puis des
athlètes aussi russes biélorusses
ukrainiens pour les raisons qu'on
connaît est ce que ça a changé quelque
chose à la victoire
pour la quête au gros globe seul johan
sb peut-être edouard la tipp oeuf et la
type of le russe pouvait potentiellement
y arriver mais voilà johannes bleus a
décidé d'arrêter saison pour
circonstance voilà familial aussi mais
parce que il était un peu il pensait
trop lent pour justement cette recette
quête du gros globe donc voilà le graal
justement via ton du rang de numéro un
mondial et il gagne pas seulement sur la
course et avec un dossard sur le dos
mais vraiment sur l'enchère l'ensemble
d'une saison à la gestion de des
maladies des transports de la fatigue et
puis la stabilité mentale tout en cédant
donc moi c'est le ce globe a pas moins
de saveur sans certains date est que le
ver veut de moi bien à propos de mental
vous avez vécu des saisons très
particulière il y a eu le coc vide la
plus récemment le contexte géopolitique
qui est un peu changé aussi le pool de
nation concurrente est ce que avec ce
que ça provoque d'incertitude et de
capacité à se réorganiser est ce que
c'est quelque chose qui épuise plus que
d'ordinaire et qui demande du coup
d'être peut-être plus costaud dans sa
tête mentalement
ça c'est des dix points que je contrôle
pas en fait je peux être capable de loi
là de contrôler ma performance de notre
préparation beaucoup de choses mais ça
c'est je vois là je sais pas j'ai pas la
main là dessus je ne suis pas président
de
de russie je suis pas voilà grand dieu
qui peut contrôler les virus qui
voyage sur la planète finalement j'ai
pas de pouvoir d'action là dessus donc
j'essaie de relativiser par rapport à
tout ça mais malgré tout et c'est assez
ça a été assez dur parce que ben
l'enchaînement du coc vide a fait que
j'ai l'impression de vivre à vase clos
depuis depuis deux ans et que le partage
avec le public est vraiment très très
restreint je suis quasiment pas vu ma
famille pendant pendant un hiver et puis
pour parler de la guerre ben c'est
quelque chose qui me touche parce que ça
montre à quel point le sport de sport
tout court le sport de haut niveau la
compétition est fragile dans ce genre de
situation et voilà si ça vient un
dégénéré marley j'imagine que je vais
vite me retrouver au chômage et
peut-être avec une arme à la main mais
pas pour les mêmes raisons donc j'espère
que non vous le souhaite pas vous ne
cachez pas depuis plusieurs années votre
ambition et votre envie de gagner bon là
c'est devant vous un très concrètement
dans des métaux plus ou moins différents
il faut prendre avec cette victoire là
tout ce qui va avec y compris la
notoriété comme on fait le jurassien que
vous êtes c'était c'est beaucoup plus
dur d'aller chercher tout ça que de
gérer un autorités donc finalement je
prends ça avec assez de détachement et n
relâchement je prends les choses un peu
comme comme elle arrive mais non ça fait
je me suis un petit peu préparés même si
j'ai beaucoup plus préparé la quête de
ces résultats que l'après carrière et de
ce qu'il pouvait se passer alors je me
suis plutôt bien entouré en essayant
d'anticiper tout ça mais c'est assez
nouveau pour le moment mais ça se passe
bien c'est clair que c'est comme dire un
problème de riche de riches qui gagnent
il ya deux départs en équipe de france
de biathlon quasiment de votre
génération à simon desthieux et anaïs
bescond ça vaut confirme dans la
position
de l'ancien dans une équipe de france
qui joue beaucoup la carte de la
transmission pour garder cette densité
assez extraordinaire de champion vous
même vous avez je vois les d'une
certaine façon de martin fourcade pour
ne citer que lui est ce qu'avec ces
départs la vôtre rôle dans l'équipe va
changer ou comment est-ce que vous
assumez cette position peut-être un peu
plus nouvelle qu'elle a beau temps ouais
c'est déjà avec tristesse que j'ai
appris le départ de ces deux athlètes on
a partagé énormément de bons moments et
on a là une norme respect à six deux
athlètes à nice et simon et qui j'ai
partagé il partage énormément de de
super maman donc oui je sais c'est
triste d'apprendre leur départ mais ce
statut de leader c'est vrai qu'il était
un peu plus floue à l'iso n'y est pas
c'est parce que ben martin étaient
présents emilien jacquelin ou s'il était
était bien présent et voilà il se
démarquer par ses énormes performances
donc finalement c'était un peu plus flou
cette année c'est vrai que là je prend
clairement le statut de leader sans sans
contestation avec avec cette magnifique
saison mais j'aime de plus en plus ça a
étayé pas quelque chose que j'aurais
aimé avoir trop vite dans ma carrière
mais finalement je suis dans une phase
où où j'ai envie d'amener mon équipe à
la faire progresser on
fonctionne beaucoup en collectif en
équipe de france et ce partage est hyper
important et c'est une force vraiment
l'équipe de france tous que finalement
la la la progression de l'équipe me sert
aussi à moi directement est-ce que vous
remettrez en jeu ses belles médailles
qui sont devant vous dans quatre ans en
italie ouais bien entendu les jeux de
cortina la candidature me plaît vraiment
ans à 1,6 tonne sur le site de biathlon
ainsi qu'on connaît très bien anterselva
où j'ai eu pas mal de réussite donc
c'est à une une olympiade qui me plaît
que je mets comme objectif ça vous
changera peut-être des températures
chinoise je pense qu'on retrouve à des
conditions plus clémentes que c'est
qu'en chine est j'espère un énorme
ferveur
ouais peut-être plus de public pour le
coup d'ici là ce sera peut-être sorti de
cette histoire merci beaucoup d'avoir
répondu à vos questions de france 24
quentin filles en mayenne bravo encore
pour ces belles médailles et ses globes
merci à isabelle sarthon et cécile
bertrand qui m'ont aidé à préparer cette
interview l'info continue sur dans notre
cas
[Musique]